good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Monday after a
very long weekend without the toast we
apologize we really do but I can't lie
we were so busy we were educating the
youth we were that I'm not actually I'm
not even sorry it didn't feel like a
long weekend for us because it was so
busy with education lecture lecture
lecture educate educate educate it's not
like we feel like we had a long weekend
so leisurely but this week is an
exciting week one turdulillah is in
Florida yes if you're watching on
YouTube Jackie and I are in our Duo
studio and we have the flamingos which
have been forsaken for so long for too
long we have the stressed brother and
they're both in studio today wanting to
work with their mommies it's a Bryce
Trice charity Lou and Jax Affair which
is so
sumptuous
you know what it is
harmonious yes
um so Jax and I are back in studio we
apologize for not having a show on
Friday but we were really kind of
honored to have been asked to speak at
the University of Miami School of Law
what like it's hard we gave a gorgeous
kind of really educational funny
heartwarming panel on the business of
podcasting it was so much fun it was so
much fun the it was for like the sports
Global entertainment and Sports
Marketing something like that yeah and
we were the keynote speakers we had no
idea no literally keynote someone must
have dropped out at the last minute but
it's fine no we've had this on the books
for a while that's true actually and we
don't feel like that that influencer who
dropped out at the last minute that you
invited me oh yeah you're right okay now
we were asked like months ago maybe even
years at this point yeah
um it was so much fun so many toasty
lawyers you know the next generation of
lawyers is looking to be extremely
toasty which gives me faith in the
judicial system well a lot of things
should give you faith in the judicial
system because we have a legal story
today that's Steven Smith know about
Gwyneth Paltrow oh yeah wow it's really
been a long time we haven't caught up on
that yeah that was like the headline of
the weekend really the stories are
interesting gonna spark some interesting
conversation there's one that I'm really
excited to talk about but other than
that I wouldn't be here today for the
stories I would be here today for the
Jackson Claude in person energy yes the
Bryson strikes energy yeah but the
Bryson streis energy is so combative
these two Brethren you guys like Claudia
and I don't talk about this a lot but
our boys like don't like each other
there's like not a great buy between
them they really do not [__] with one
another whatsoever they couldn't be more
different I know and like Theo is a lot
older than Bruno and more not a lot but
like he's a in dog years he's more
mature yeah he's very mature he doesn't
he doesn't want to play with anyone it's
not a Bruno thing it's a playing thing
yeah no Theo's not really like a super
social dog actually he really just loves
his parents and he loves people he does
not like love other dogs no but he
doesn't even like the kids
he doesn't understand the kids but he
loves all adults like he really does
yeah yeah these boys are lovers they
just don't really have a lot in common
yeah and there are different stages of
their life and that's okay no it is okay
but it's just something like this
weekend you were on a staycation yeah so
Jackie and Olivia both helped me out a
lot Theo stayed here in Florida while
Ben and I took a little birthday trip to
Bell Harbor at the St Regis can't
recommend it off gorgeous facility
um and spent like a little staycation
weekend you know swimming Ocean Beach I
have such a bad sunburn it's killing me
my bun pulling back my forehead in this
updo with the sunburn that I have like I
could go to the hospital
um but it was so nice and I knew that
Theo was in good you know is it not dog
friendly it was but you don't want him
in the room all day yeah what we're we
were at the beach all day and we I'm not
gonna take him to the beach and I'm not
gonna leave him in like the room it was
really just not it was a very uh pet
friendly kid-friendly Hotel I told you
you should maybe take a trip down there
it was so nice but I'm happy to be back
you know it felt weird to be in the
great state of Florida without my family
I was like what am I doing here it was
weird for everyone it was weird no you
should have been here it was like a
weirdness like we have a pool here yes
on here so true let me tell you two
things I wanted to share the first I
just wanted to like close a loop on
something we spoke about the last time I
was in Florida
if you're not watching on YouTube I'm
going into my pocket
I took it this morning I walked into
Jackie's studio and the aforementioned
20 40 that has been sitting in here
since you moved into this home was still
sitting there which proves that I need
it more than you do so I have to pick up
some supplies like the lucky 40 though I
have to pick up some supplies for a
little birthday party we're throwing for
Ben so I'll just tell Ben that your gift
to him was the forty dollars for
balloons Etc okay you'll tell him that I
set up the day course I will tell him
that you no I would tell them that you
paid you supply the budget for the decor
um and the second thing I wanted to tell
you is like kind of something weird I
did over the weekend that I just wanted
to tell you that immediately made me
think of you okay so me and Ben were on
the beach and we ran into our friends
Ben and Margie and they're such a great
couple they have two kids and their kids
are so cute and their kids are the exact
same age as uh Olivia's kids Michaela
and Levi so I just feel like you know
I'm always saying I feel like I know
more about like motherhood than the
average Auntie but it's important to
note I am not a mother but like
sometimes I say things like I said
something so out of [__] pocket I
actually felt weird
so they came over with their kids on the
beach with the stroller and we were like
so happy to see their kids Leo Leo and
Jack so I was like oh my God we were
asking so many questions because I
haven't seen them in so long they live
in Florida and I really haven't seen Leo
maybe like since his bris and I was like
is that the older one the older one the
one that's Michaela's age so he's like
three now and I was asking so many
questions I was like oh what is he this
is he potty trained and he she was like
yeah he's potty trained and I was like
it is so hard to potty train kids and me
a person who's literally never potty
trained a child but Margie was like no
actually like I mean Leah was like
really good I was like oh
okay
cool
um I don't know why the [__] I said that
I've literally never potty trained a
child and like I'm talking to somebody
who has right but I would say like the
crime there is not that you've never
potty trained a child because like
you're speaking from your personal
experience with Michaela but it would be
applying your one experience to the
whole of children no and my experience
is like literally one time I thought she
had to pee and I sat her down on the
toilet no but your experience is also
hearing it through Olivia yes and
getting the play-by-play but it's not
the same as Margie's who's like an
actual mom of two yeah but you know what
it's better than the opposite where the
person who's not a mother is like down
playing how hard things are and the
mom's like
no I respect mothers everybody knows
that I respect mothers right I'd rather
talk to someone who like is
overestimating how hard it is rather
than someone who's down minimizing it
yeah yeah that's true okay thanks for
making me feel better yeah yeah you're
fine you're in that moment I was like
okay that was weird
I wish I didn't say that sometimes you
just like say stuff to like round out
the conversation which like relate you
know no no but like sometimes you just
have to like say a statement to keep the
combo moving for the conversation and
sometimes it's a not 100 accurate
helpful or useful
and I think we've all done that at some
point in our life thanks Jack and
someone was just listening a little too
closely to call out the inaccuracies
yeah that was me no no that was her like
actually listening to what you said and
yeah like actually no yeah thanks Margie
for not just like
ignoring just like fake faking
conversation yeah yeah she was so intent
she was so intense she was intentional
intention is so important
we are intentional don't you find I find
that we are constantly intentionalizing
and being extremely intensive yeah yeah
feels good doesn't it it feels almost
intentional
um so we have a great show tell me about
your weekend like tell me tell me
everything because I wasn't here but I
was like nearby kind of not really I had
a great like fun loving weekend it just
was a lot of
I don't need child care yeah like but I
don't know what the word would be just
like
physically like it was there was no
stopping there was no stopping you know
and like there was just so much going on
and you know you just gotta keep making
[__] up making games making different
scenarios in which they could play like
so true it was exhausting but rewarding
well isn't that just motherhood in a
nutshell it is it is I feel bad it's for
me like whenever I spend time here
uninterrupted it's like hours and hours
of like taking care of the kids not like
stopping in saying hi I'm just
constantly in awe of like exhaustion is
not a word in these kids vocabulary no
it's crazy like get tired [__] I know
and sometimes they do take like a big
nap and it's like oh I guess if I slept
that long in the middle of the day I'd
have more energy too but sometimes they
don't [__] not I know
well you know I'm staying at Olivia's
this time and it's been so nice honestly
to spend time like not too nice right
it's been just like nice it's been just
equally as nice as it is here okay
you're great but I've really gotten in
and I've only been here for like you
know 12 hours it has been really
restorative in my relationship with
Michaela she is she's also grown up in a
lot a lot in like the two months that
I've been here she's
obsessed with antiquoia like woke me up
this morning wants to play last night
before bed oh my God so we put her bed
at like eight and then at like 10
o'clock we're watching the CMT Awards
and we hear Michaela and she was singing
of course High School Musical because I
came down here with the I watched High
School Musical 3 the day before I left
for Florida and I said this is a film
Makayla would love and I knew it so I
put it on for her last night and she was
obsessed with the final scene where
they're graduating uh I was your messed
up my life to feel just like a high
school you guys know it she was obsessed
so at 10 she like still wasn't asleep so
Zach pulled her out and then Olivia and
him got into bed and Michaela like laid
with them for a little bit so before me
and Ben went to bed I went into their
room to say good night so of course I
had to climb into the middle and give
Michaela like a big hug and she touches
my nose and she goes
your makeup it's beautiful
and I wasn't even wearing any makeup so
she really just thinks I'm beautiful and
Michaela learned like all my friends and
family learned the weight of my heart is
through flattery yeah it was amazing it
was like one of those moments where like
your heart just like bursts into a
million pieces no I know that's how I
felt when I shared that that other
anecdote with you about Michaela that
you didn't believe but do you maybe
believe it now about Evermore
I don't remember the song Evermore no I
don't believe that even after like
knowing like getting sure share with
everyone because it was honestly like I
know Michaela's capabilities and like
she just isn't there yet you know she is
because Olivia told me the story she
texted it to me the next day yeah and
Olivia I think was just like really
wanting to make anti-sac feel good but
anti-sac feels good like and I just I
don't really need validation falsify I
don't believe it so Michaela loves
Beauty and the Beast their whole
family's favorite song from Beauty and
the Beast is Evermore which is on the
new uh live action one sung by Josh
Groban
and queen has taste Queen has taste so
the lyrics go and I know he'll never
leave me even as I fade from you and she
likes to sing in her crib like
beforehand in the mornings whatever and
Olivia could hear her singing and she
was singing Evermore what she's saying
and I know anti-sac will never leave me
that didn't [__] happen
it just didn't have them but why can't
like we both have nice anecdotes it's
just like okay you remember that tweet
that went viral oh yes this is one of my
favorite things somebody tweeted like
something there's like like
four-year-old did that was so like sweet
but like so unbelievable that somebody
quote tweeted it and was like this did
not happen yeah and
that's how I feel okay that's not how I
feel it's so unbelievable I need to
witness it with my own eyes when it
comes to Kayla yeah maybe I'm
underestimating her maybe you are maybe
I am maybe you are so it's just been
it's been amazing to be with the kids
these last like five minutes I'm so
happy to be here I'm here for the whole
week it's Passover so just a little
housekeeping reminder Wednesday and
Thursday there are no episodes of the
toast is Jackie and I will be observing
the late great holiday of pizza but we
filmed a vlog on Friday yeah because as
we stated like we spoke at University of
Miami School of Law yeah and not just
like the University of Miami it was like
the University of Miami school law right
it wasn't like one of the other schools
that don't sound like as impressive as
school of life and it certainly wasn't
like undergrads we weren't talking to
teenagers like we were talking to
professional adults yeah so we filmed a
vlog that day of get ready with us we
did our makeup together it was really
harmonious it was it started off a
little acrimonious it did it takes it's
it's tense like we were rushing we
rushed we were vlogging we were doing
our makeup we both want to look our best
Claudia is working with her Florida set
of materials which are apparently
already outdated they are uh so we've
logged the get ready with us process and
then a little bit of our day but it's
mostly like our makeup routines chit
chatting about the day and having some
girly swirly time girl I swearly time so
that will be up Wednesday in lieu of an
episode of the toast and we are planning
to have something for you Thursday as
well so if you never want to go a
weekday without toast
patriot.patreon.com the toast because I
think if you like include patreon then I
really don't know when's the last week
day that we haven't had something we're
always taking care of the patreon
members that's one thing about us yeah
fun fact yeah that way you never have to
go without turdy Lou Jackson gone yeah
okay yeah do you feel as though I feel
as though do you feel as though I do
feel as though and we have like a busy
day today so it's like we have gotta get
to Stepping yeah so past we Jack and I
are sharing one iPad today so we're
gonna have to be like passing by we're
very sustainable yeah Greta tune would
approve she would say how dare you
impress me so much I'm just gonna go in
any order does that work okay
just pass over the um no I don't like
this order I got it the first five yeah
I got it great okay
without further Ado About the Rivalry
between Dew and Brew here are the fast
five stories that you need to know
and the fast five stories that you
absolutely need to know are is brought
to you by Squarespace so Squarespace is
everything and anything for websites if
you're looking to start an e-commerce
website you work in e-commerce you want
to start a side hustle literally
anything check out Squarespace it is the
all-in-one platform to build a beautiful
online presence and run your business
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is really the place for it
all so there's tons of product features
on squarespace's websites um depending
on what you are looking to create online
but if it's e-commerce Squarespace is
the place to sell anything they have the
tools you need to get your business off
the ground including e-commerce
templates inventory management a simple
checkout process and of course secure
payments whatever you sell Squarespace
has merchandising features to make your
product look at their best online if
you're looking to maybe do something in
the education space you can do email
campaigns with Squarespace you can grow
and engage your audience with
Squarespace email campaigns you can
create powerful email content that
matches your website with your existing
product your blog post your logo so that
you're messaging is staying consistent
and effective let's say you want to do
something in the tech space they've got
Squarespace member areas so you can
connect with your audience and generate
Revenue through gated members only
content you can manage your members send
email Communications leverage your
audience insights all on one easy to use
platform also the great part about
Squarespace is they offer a one-click
Content ownership so you own all the
content that you put on your Squarespace
platform it's a one-click data
portability check out squarespace.com
toast for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use offer code toast to
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or a domain again that's
squarespace.com toast for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch use
offer code toast to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
today's episode is also brought to you
by Perfect bar looking for nutritious
and delicious snack
well look no further than perfect bar
with their lineup of fresh from the
fridge protein bars perfect bar is
exactly what you and your family need
made with freshly ground nut butter
organic honey and 20 organic superfoods
perfect bar has a variety of products
like protein bars little snack size bars
that are also good and good for you
you'll be sure to find something you
love they have tons of different flavors
but make sure to check out the chocolate
chip cookie dough because the texture is
just Supreme and what's great about
perfect bars that you keep it in the
fridge because it's so fresh fresh to
death that the inside is like this
really kind of doughy cookie dough
texture but the outside is like a hard
shell of chocolate it's absolutely
delicious so the creamy dough texture is
full of flavor and they're unlike any
other bars out there and they now come
in snack sizes and those snack sizes are
packed with up to six grams of protein
and 150 calories so a little goes a long
way throw it in your purse at the
beginning of a long day you'll be glad
you have it because they're made with
whole food ingredients and they contain
zero artificial preservatives perfect
bar is stored in the fridge so grab one
after a workout for a quick bite while
you're out shopping or just whenever if
if you're not sold yet they're also
non-GMO project verified gluten-free soy
free low GI and kosher
perfect bar knows that it'll be Love At
First Bite so for a limited time they're
offering you a chance to try the
refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works sign up for email or
text and upload a picture of your
receipt from your local grocery store
and they'll reimburse you for the cost
of one bar it'll go directly into your
venmo or PayPal account all you have to
do is go to perfect snacks.com toast to
get that free perfect bar today that's
perfect snacks.com toast to get a free
perfect bar today
thank you turdy Lou yeah
what can I say except you're welcome
also we have we're recapping succession
no we are I don't watch it why not
because like we didn't talk about it
excuse me and I'm staying at the
Shapiro's and they didn't watch last
week's episode so we're not recapping it
I'm so sorry
like we didn't talk about like doing
that what's to talk about like we have a
schedule I'm like not in my house my
time is on my mind you literally put a
gun to my head like for pump rules yeah
of course I'm in session last week I put
it onto your head for pump rules for
sure because that's so pertinent we're a
pop culture show how can we not be
watching pump rules right now
um I was tired one night we were
literally talking about succession at
dinner last night and you didn't say
anything and then Olivia was like I
haven't watched the first episode of the
season so like how could I watch it I'm
staying at her house in your bedroom in
your quarters
not spend time with my family I didn't
watch it so let's just move on I'm so
sorry
I'm gonna remember this can't wait I
can't wait I stand by the fact that I
did nothing wrong
you would oh my God if you watch it and
I didn't watch it even though like we
agreed like this is part of the
programming now no but like we didn't
talk about it like we didn't discover
something to say we were together last
night I feel like we're always like
we're making sure like if there's
something to do like we're on top of
each other because you mentioned it like
Sensations on tonight like I knew that
you knew and that you were on top of it
no I didn't watch it and I refused to be
blamed any longer for this grotesque
Miss Alliance like I didn't I I
literally didn't do anything wrong I'm
like my God okay I'm just like really
excited for when sometime I don't watch
something
that you bought but see the thing is
like if I watch something I always tell
you
at the dinner table I don't go Rogue and
just watch it you know we talked about
it at the dinner table I didn't know you
came away from that conversation being
like I won't watch
well then you maybe you don't really
understand me no I guess it was a
misunderstanding
I shock it up to a misunderstanding and
keep the harmonious Vibes the
unfortunate thing though is that if this
were a remote episode you could just
take your headphones off I know
too bad I can't be silenced
hmm
okay well
I did have well now do I feel great
oh
I feel just like you know useless
no
it's you went to see the episode there's
only a few things to say
all right do you like would it be
helpful if I watch it today so we can
bring up it tomorrow or just get back on
the train next week we could recap it
tomorrow if you find you don't have to
watch it today though like if it wasn't
for Mondays like recap like we don't
we're not in any Rush okay like I'm like
I apologize like I I still don't feel
like I did anything like wrong per se I
just I I'm sorry that we found ourselves
in this situation I'm sorry I'm sorry
too I'm sorry you like had to wait up
when I know you actually don't even like
like the show anymore you know yeah no
it did my schedule is fine I literally
finished my book for the redheads like
two minutes before we started watching
so like it was fine I'm sorry um but it
was just like an hour of sleep I could
have gone back no that's so true and as
a mother like the fact that I took away
that hour of sleep for me like I
definitely I definitely feel
maybe I should just go like I why don't
you just go watch it right now and then
I know we actually don't have time for
that okay but it's fine it's fine
hopefully I still feel passionate
whenever we do talk about it okay our
first story Gwyneth Paltrow thinks the
jury for their thoughtfulness after
trial win Gwyneth is happy with the
outcome and thankful to the jury after
winning her ski crash trial in Utah
she said I felt that acquiescing to a
false claim compromised my Integrity I
am pleased with the outcome and I
appreciate all the hard work of Judge
Holmberg and the jury and thank them for
their thoughtfulness in handling this
case nearly one hour before she posted
that a jury decided that the retired Dr
Terry Sanderson was 100 at fault for
their 2016 ski crash despite him suing
Gwyneth for three hundred thousand
dollars
I just feel like when they say he's
suing Gwyneth for 300 000 like it's such
a lie like he was suing her for more and
the judge captain at 300 000 but what
did he initially want to sue her for
like three million three million or one
million so that's just like crazy now I
really just didn't think there was a way
I could ever like love Gwyneth Paltrow
more like I've been a ride or die for
her for many years and this trial is
just like brought out another side of
Gwyneth first of all like the Luke's
were so like
but also like you know you have to look
appropriate in um in court I just
thought she looked amazing I loved you
know the everyday paparazzi photos of
what bag is she wearing what gorgeous
flowy skirt will she be wearing today so
that was exciting too I loved seeing her
testimony how just unbothered Queen you
know yeah I loved um watching this guy
like really truly embarrass himself and
I believe he gave a statement
basically saying you know like I'm
embarrassed you know oh wow yeah so I
loved that I loved every bit of this
trial I love that she won I love that
the jury you know I feel I feel as
though you know you could have with
cases like this a lot of people have
preconceived notions about celebrities
and they could have let that
be a bias of theirs because you know one
of the things about Gwyneth Paltrow that
people think is like she didn't she's
better than everyone she's you know kind
of pretentious so you know shoving into
someone and keep skiing is something a
pretentious person would do so I'm glad
that the the jury didn't let their
bias get in the way well you would hope
that there weren't jury people who had
biases
um Gwyneth I would think that in the
selection it would be mostly people who
are familiar and yeah yeah too cool for
that
um she was so gracious when the trial
was over they let the uh
what's the word I'm looking for
defendant and the plaintiff like Gwyneth
and Terry they got to leave first so
Gwyneth got up and was walking out and
she had to walk past Terry and she came
over to him and she said I wish you the
best yes which was very gracious but I
like to think it was like a little knife
a little jab because like yeah you know
and it's also like I wish you well
because like you're unwell I said good
day sir yeah no like I hope you get the
help that you need for being so deeply
Disturbed that you would spend time on
this far that was definitely the subtext
of the I wish you well that it was get
help but on the surface it was very
gracious yes um and I also loved her
statement because I had said you know
she's definitely spending more money on
this trial and everything in legal fees
than she would in just paying this guy
300 000 and what you said very very uh
studiously was that
some things are worth protecting your
reputation people just don't want their
image to be dragged because it's more
cost effective and that's exactly what
she said in her name and she's like I
could have just acquiesced the money but
like my legacy means more to me than the
money and I just
every and it's about the principle right
right because if anybody can just oh of
course say that gwenna's crashed into
them and get 300K then what's to stop
the next person and the next person yeah
just finds it easier to pay them off so
at every step of this trial I have been
in awe of gwyneth's Elegance Grace
composure and style and I don't know if
I could love for any more than I do but
I but I did but I now do I do yeah I do
you do I will miss watching this the
footage was really like I just love
seeing celebrities in something so
ugly like trial you know I think that's
why celebrity trials like you know
Johnny and Amber and anytime like a
celebrity's on trial become such a
spectacle one because it's a celebrity
but two it's like we're used to seeing
celebrities in this glamorous but
there's something so normal and like
routine and common almost about
yeah there's no special treatment no and
it was just it was all very exciting
there's no special lighting you're all
on fluorescent the fluorescence it was
just exciting yes so I'm glad that
justice has been served closing the book
on that
congrats Gwyneth Justin
has been served there's a gavel around
here somewhere I think right we split
them up in did we yeah in the divorce
stop I'm depressed I know what's a
better word for it in the move in the
relocation that sounds like you got
fired but
no it was relocated she was relocated
are you ready for our next story yeah
just listen before just to listen okay
before like you make a face because Pete
Davidson I know did a podcast on
someone's patreon so thumbs up for
patreon people making making money off
their content we'd love to see content
being monetized he did had a
conversation with John Bernthal uh for
his podcast real ones which you can
listen to this episode on his patreon
and he expressed feeling like a loser
you could listen to our patreon oh yeah
no no but once you get comfortable with
the patreon platform in general you want
to support other creators and why don't
we just be like number two after that so
true when we're typically number one of
course of course
um but he expressed feeling like a loser
because of the ongoing emphasis on who
he was dating he said quote I'm in my
20s and I've dated people and for some
reason that's very crazy and interesting
to people I don't think it's interesting
I've been in Show Business for like half
my life almost for 14 or 15 years and on
a national TV show in 12 years I've
dated 10 people I don't think that's
crazy but to some people that's very
interesting that became all anyone would
talk about he said it's not like I was
flexing you know what I mean and these
people that I've dated I met them at
work I wasn't in anyone's DMS no one was
in mine I worked at one of the five
Hollywood epicenters of where you meet
people and that's how it happened it's a
good call he said suddenly you're in the
Zeitgeist that has nothing to do with
the work and that's a really shitty
feeling I became more known before the
work was there but I was always working
he qualified that he's cool with the
joke he gets the late night jokes but
occasionally the laughter over his
romantic track record hit too close to
home like when they made fun of him on
his own show SNL he said when your own
show pokes fun at you I'd be sitting in
the back watching the cold open and the
cold open is topical political humor
whatever's in the culture and then
making fun of you then you've got to
walk out and do a sketch next and hit
your mark and the show just made fun of
you so why are they gonna laugh at you
like they just dogged you in front of
everyone man and you're like I'm a
[__] loser man okay really quickly I
know this is like not the point of the
conversation but let's try name the 12
girls that he's dated okay
David Harley acquilino and opposite but
yeah yeah yeah I'm trying to go oh you
want to go okay so Carly Cassie Ariana
Kate Beckinsale okay that was such a
great time
um
I don't know if this is in order Phoebe
Denver oh Phoebe Denver yeah let's not
go in order
Kim Kim
uh Chase now Chase now
maybe there were some like nobodies no
there was probably some like three dates
you know like spotted with let's
personally I'm still shipping him and
came back and sell like I just thought
that was like a cute Moment In Time Pete
Davidson's dating history let's see if
we're missing anyone Margaret Qualley
Margaret quality that's nine like she's
just like Tiger but we did oh Olivia
O'Brien oh yeah yeah even though that
was like a text yeah she's actually been
talking about that recently on some
podcasts because uh I don't know why but
she was like I think they maybe went on
one date yeah she said on BFF's pod yeah
she and the comic had a secret
short-lived fling admitting that she
didn't she did not think anyone knew
about it because they asked her about it
and she's like I didn't think anyone
knew she further claimed that he called
things off via text he texted me and was
like I'm seeing someone else so like I
can't I think it was Phoebe Denver yeah
and also we like dissected this at the
time and their relationship didn't seem
to qualify for like an actual break
oh yeah we did I remember
that was last week yeah that's 11. yeah
but that's everyone
yeah no it's not that crazy I I
definitely um
I see what he's saying but I also feel
like it's probably like somewhat
important to note that
his career also blew up because of it
like he was able to leave SNL
and have other opportunities because
he's so famous now because of who he
dated you know I disagree a little bit I
don't think it like worked against him
it only worked against him in the sense
of like that's you know the headline
about him but
I feel like even before he started
having high profile relationships he was
always like the really funny youngest
cast member ever on SNL and like was
going places yeah and would and would be
doing the same work that he's doing
without the girlfriends honestly no I
don't I don't know I don't think so but
what what is he doing that's so big like
honestly nothing I don't know what he
did so what did this get him but he does
like a lot he like makes a lot of money
from being famous like he was like a
Calvin Klein face okay he was in a
Hellman's commercial and he's like
career as a comic though yeah but that
those things like afford you the
privilege of not having to work like you
make a lot of money and you can chill
and you have to go to SNL every week you
know but he's working still like he's
only in his 20s oh he's ever tired yeah
no I think he does like shows and he
actually has some projects in the works
something coming out that this was
promoting oh he was just in that horror
movie bodies bodies bodies but guess May
4th on peacock yeah it is true that like
he's more of a
a celebrity right now then he is a comic
and I think that hurts him yeah and he's
only a celebrity because of those
relationships and that makes him feel
like a loser well you know Pete like at
least you're a celebrity okay some of us
are out here trying to be grateful no of
course like you could always make the
case that things could be so much worse
yeah but he's just sharing truth on
patreon like he's not bothering anyone
no he's not bothering anyone his truth
is bothering no one right so he's
allowed to say how he feels what's Pete
going through what is his teeth think
because that's his opinion but you would
think that all of these feelings would
stop him from tearing through the women
of Hollywood right and be a little bit
more low-key one well the thing is he
said he is low-key like he doesn't have
Instagram it's not like he's like here's
me and my girl and he literally like
it's just he can't help that no but it's
not even like red carpet Paparazzi it's
like literally one lone paparazzo
following him into that forlorn building
with him and emrada yeah but also like
the pictures of him on vacation with
Chase like there's always it's always
pictures I also think like a lot of the
women he dates know that he's like a PR
magnate and I think a lot of them like
lean into that like I I feel like a lot
of the news that came out about him and
emrada were like emrada putting it out
or emrata's people like having the
paparazzi there because she was very
much trying to like pin it to her ex
yeah that's possible but you know if
you're gonna go on a date with Pete
Davidson it's gonna be written up
everywhere so it's like oh I landed a
date with date with Pete Davidson call
everyone yeah and I think that hurts him
I think it does too because it's like
you really not to be so cliche it's like
you never know if someone's dating you
for you right and you know what they
didn't go out again after that so maybe
he was like oh no she's just thirsty
she's thirsty and and I can't afford
like another
kerfuffle another thing yeah yeah
because I'm trying to focus on babkus
which premieres May 4th on peacock so I
hope like it really works out with him
and Chase because she's kind of like
unknown I don't think people really care
so much about this relationship except
they like you know drove into someone's
house right
um no but it's the thing is it's not at
this point it's not about the girl it's
about p and it's about like adding to
that number yeah but I definitely feel
like there's less Fanfare for him and
Chase like there was like Paparazzi
pictures but no one really cares like
she's new to the on the scene no they
care we just don't talk about it every
day but like every day I look for
articles like if they're doing something
like they're there yeah but like do the
people care I feel like they don't drop
a comment because I I like I personally
don't care I mean most of these articles
that I see in the morning are just like
most of the articles that I see in the
morning it's like who the [__] is
reading this who gives us [__] who are
they about oh my God it's just like
everyone so and so celebrates her dad
like we live in a culture let me go to
page six days hold on Brutal we live in
a culture where like somebody leaving an
Instagram comment is worthy of an entire
article on like a pre-reputable news
site that's crazy and they're so
misleading it's like Khloe Kardashian
finally addresses plastic surgery can I
oh [__] this isn't going well
we're having to share an iPad and we're
both trying to look things up sharing of
the assets isn't going well but no like
People magazine today they're like top
stories
number literally number two the
bachelor's Madison Pruitt trout shares
what she's obsessed with this spring
well that's by the way that's another
element of moronise when it comes to
journalism these days it's like
publicists
bring their clients and get
opportunities for their clients like
Interview With People magazine and it's
like I'm just using Madison Peru as an
example but I see it with like all these
kind of low-level influencers and
reality stars
here's the 10 things that Maddie Pruitt
can't live without here's the eight
beauty secrets that she keeps in her
purse Claudia Alicia Silverstone shares
adorable video of her dog sitting at the
dinner table quote waiting for his turn
listen you guys it's hard out here so
when you get upset with Jackie for
stories just know like this is what
she's dealing with okay The Last of Us
star Bella Ramsey loves to eat corn
flakes with orange juice it's so good
the last of us start Bella Ramsey sounds
disgusting why would literally anybody
eat that instead of milk and then also
like okay and then this was on page six
day which I thought was just such like a
nasty who gives a [__] headline which
was Marilyn Nichols seemingly who's
Marilee nickel Tristan's
Marilyn Nichols seemingly Shades Khloe
Kardashian's lavish birthday party for
True like I don't know Marilyn Nichols
is not a famous person I don't care what
she maybe or maybe did not shade Chloe
about yeah and what was it like an
Instagram comment I I didn't I did not
dignify it by click click I did not yeah
I just
I feel like it's you know all part of a
larger conversations you know in the
digital age what does that mean for
journalism
no it's not looking good it's not
looking good by any means and then like
there there are like I feel like
Publications that try and maintain like
journalistic integrity and like write
thought-provoking articles and then they
have absolutely nothing and they also
have nothing to work with like they're
trying to make thought provocation out
of Alicia silverstone's dog sitting at
the table but what does her dog sitting
at the table really mean for culture
what is he waiting for at the table
right and how did he get there what was
the journey to the table like
it's insane these are questions worth
asking
don't you agree I do and I would love to
get into the next story when it's time
not too bad oh because it's not time
that's too bad for you Jackie yo because
it is not time I must let everyone know
that today's episode is brought to you
by ZipRecruiter whether you're starting
a new business or growing one if you
want to be successful you need the most
talented people on your team and that's
where ZipRecruiter comes in and right
now you can try ZipRecruiter for free
when you go to ziprecruiter.com toast
Jackie if you could start a new business
what would you be because like I have so
many ideas you know I would start a
conglomerate called turdy Lou Global
where we just sort of like acquire a lot
of businesses and take over the world
and what kind of people would you need
working at turdyloo Global people with
the turdy loose Spirit right and work
ethic well here's which I couldn't
describe to but I would know it if I saw
it on ZipRecruiter here's my pitch
Jackie this is why you should let zip
recruiter help you hire for your
business Turtle Global LLC zip
recruiters powerful matching technology
finds highly qualified candidates for a
wide range of roles if you've got your
eye on one or two people who'd be
perfect for your job ZipRecruiter will
actually let you send them a personal
invite making them more likely to apply
Jackie so ZipRecruiter is the place to
go because they also offer attention
grabbing tools that speak to your job
flexibility like remote training
provided
urgent
FaceTime with turdy Lou and more it'll
really help your job stand out to the
candidates
let ZipRecruiter fill all your roles
with all the right candidates four out
of five employers who post on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day see for yourself
and go to the exclusive link of
ziprecruiter.com toast to try
ZipRecruiter for free you'll only be
able to try for free when you go to
ziprecruiter.com toast ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire today's episode is also
it is also Jackie brought to you by all
birds
that's exciting isn't it yeah because I
love my all birds you do yeah they're so
comfortable and I can Bop around in them
I don't have to wear socks with them if
I don't want to sometimes just sucks
cramp your style that's because all
birds are made with nature in mind
they're made with materials from nature
you know yeah that's us natural queens
and we're so natural but it's like what
are we gonna go outside and make shoes
out of your orange tree no we're not so
we let the people at all birds do all
the work because in the all birds
Innovation lab they research how to make
the most out of sustainable materials
like leather made from Plants sugar cane
and tree fibers their materials are so
natural one might even say that they're
Supernatural try the plant Pacer the
tree Dasher or the super light to see
for yourself how super super can really
get all right so all birds make fabulous
shoes for a multitude of reasons just
like we said they're made from all
natural materials personally I love them
because you can throw them in the
washing machine so it's like you don't
have to walk around being like oh I
can't go outside it's raining you know
like people who are very protective over
their shoes especially if you've got
them in a light color no run around do
what you got to do and then throw them
in the washing machine so the all birds
Innovation lab
um is their home for sciencey stuff like
research and testing renewable materials
the plant Pacer which is the leather
made from Plants
um is made with all birds 100 plastic
free and 100 vegan plant leather the
tree Dasher which is their running shoe
made from wood are uh Splinter free
because it's not really wood they look
like a piece of wood they're mate you
look like a piece of wood they're made
with natural materials like eucalyptus
tree fiber for a lighter and more
responsive shoe so all birds is making
shoes better than natural they're
Supernatural find your perfect pair at
allbirds.com and use code toast to get a
free pair of socks with a purchase of 48
or more that's all
birds.com code is toast obridge doesn't
run sales very often and they don't run
exclusive deals like this so make sure
you're going to allbirds.com use kotos
to get a free pair of socks with your
purchase of 48 or more allbirds.com code
toast they make a nice sock they do make
a nice sock at this age in my life I
can't be wearing not nice socks oh my
God that's so true and I can't be
wearing not socks at all you know on my
way to the um airport I forgot a pair of
socks and I wore a pair of sneakers not
all birds with no socks and when I tell
you I've never been so uncomfortable in
my whole life damn and that's what I get
for not wearing my tree Dashers that's
what you get that's what it serves me
right
are you ready for our next story which
is just some funny sweet unfortunately
Instagram caption news okay but I think
it's worth discussing because it's has
to do with one of our favorite quotes
and some of our favorite people so Kim
Kardashian is finally apologizing and
joking about copying her sister Chloe's
outfit that she infamously made fun of
when they went on a trip to Japan in
2018 and I'm gonna be real with you you
look like [__] clowns so Kim Chloe
and Courtney went to Japan in 2018 I
think that was when like Kim was
shooting uh Jesus on the street looking
for easy and
Chloe and Courtney I can't remember
their names right now Chloe and Courtney
were in so long because it's been really
spoke about that long Chloe and Courtney
were there like supporting their sis and
wearing their favorite Japan look right
and doing the most you know and it just
wasn't the vibe like Kim was in this
like very like spandex like a futuristic
era and then toned down very like Glam
uh Glam Tokyo Fashions colors colors
Kawaii and Kim like kind of bring them
out it's like you guys look like clowns
and I think she was like kind of ashamed
to be seen with them in their really
colorful looks guys it was funny like
now we quoted but like in the moment
like she was kind of being a [__] yeah
but in the moment it was [__] too like
I don't think in the moment we're like
yeah you guys look like no because I
know it's funny they didn't they looked
really good but they obviously weren't
matching her aesthetic which was the
reason for going to Japan in the first
place and they literally came to Japan
for her like oh I know but it's like
you're coming to Japan with me and
you're ruining my photos nobody cares
like no I know but that's important that
was important to Kim at the time she had
her priorities all the cocked at the
time she did and now she was in Japan
with her kids wearing a huge pink fuzzy
jacket the look was so cute but fans
called out that literally that's what
Chloe was wearing when she got called
the clown when they got called the clown
and Kim did a carousel of pictures in
her pink look and she included the clip
from uh that episode and someone had
tweeted like so is Chloe is Kim finally
gonna apologize to Chloe and Chloe
commented I'm waiting 100 Kim should
apologize no like Chloe ahead of the
fashion curve Chloe had a fashion curve
funny that they like got in on it before
like it was like flipped on them you
know
um
it's just it's not doing it for me you
know the story yeah you know I'm not
coming at you I know but you know when I
saw it I was like oh cute and like
they're posting like old clips and
making fun of themselves those are some
of that's my uh kind of celebrity father
I enjoy yeah yeah self-referencing to
reference we're not reference or an
offered but I wish they did throw it up
and put it in a blender I think I would
have liked this story more I'm like
really in my in terms of Kardashians
like we've been talking about I've been
feeling just kind of like you know I'm
resting yeah oh so I was wrong
apparently like there is a lot of
chatter about how they're in there yes
flop errors on Tick Tock yeah yeah we
were talking about that last week like
is it just an us thing is it a culture
thing it's very much a culture thing
um there is a lot of debate about it and
also something that I found really
interesting is I saw Liz hype post this
Kim has been like wearing a lot of
Balenciaga
okay I have a question for you
what do you I don't really own any
Valencia yeah I'm so glad you brought
this up but what do you think about
wearing Balenciaga that you already had
bought okay so I my personal policy
would be like I would if I own
Balenciaga I would wear it the things
that I own that didn't say Balenciaga
but I wouldn't walk around like with a
Balenciaga Dogo Mania purse so I um I
didn't believe I owned anything
Balenciaga and then I was getting
dressed for something and I put this
shirt on and it's just a shirt it's like
a blouse and it happened to be
Balenciaga and I didn't wear it just
because I looked fat but not because it
was one's hair if it looked good I would
have worn it because it didn't have any
labels and it's like sorry I'm not of
the means where I have like so many I
can just you know dispose of my designer
item so for a lay person I think if you
have something honestly where you spent
the money like why should you be
punished right but Kim especially with
with her clothes like everything she
wears is a statement whether she likes
that or not everything she wears is
shared you know everyone all these
closet accounts so to be to wear
something by a designer it does
feel like you're standing by that
designer and that's very different than
you doing that right when she has like
unlimited resources to clothes you
probably didn't pay for most of the
Valencia Balenciaga items that she had
where it's like regular folk [__] I
paid for this like that sucks like I'm
wearing it like I can actually
understand that right
um
so I it's a choice I believe it's a
choice
the thing is Kim has choices whereas
like other people maybe one time splurge
on a Balenciaga bag like they don't have
that many choices you know that's their
bag that's their bag yeah and you must
wear it like yeah you bought the bag now
lay with it but I like
she's wearing
non-logo Balenciaga stuff like even
she's wearing the sunglasses and she
doesn't show a picture of this it's not
like she's publicly endorsing lanziago
you kind of have to be in the know to
know that that's what she's wearing but
I agree with you that like she has the
means to go all the way I disagree
because even though it doesn't have like
the big label on it like everything she
wears is shared do you know what I mean
you're saying that then people will want
that shirt even though it doesn't say it
I'm not even saying that she might be
influencing people all I'm saying is
like her wearing an item whether it's
small like sunglasses that doesn't even
have a logo on it she knows what what
whatever she wears is publicized like
this is what she wears okay that we will
find out that it's Balenciaga nothing
we'll find out but it's it's like an
association it's an endorsement almost
yeah
I do
okay
do you feel that way about all
celebrities who like casually wear
valenciaga garments
um you're asking such great questions
because I think our issue with a lot of
celebrities casually wear now I don't
know and also now everyone makes that
turtleneck spandex top with the gloves
yeah so I'm like who's is who's it's
like new glare now too everyone yeah but
because I think the issue with Kim and
blanciago was like she threw her whole
[__] [__] yeah weight face behind this
brand that was doing unsavory things and
so like we were hopeful that she would
take a step back from them but not that
she never can wear them again you know
like it's a little soon no
I don't know like for me it was
disappointing when she continued to like
be their face but like now it's say
who's another celebrity who I if Kelly
Clarkson like had a Balenciaga top in
her closet and she happened to wear it
like I don't think that that would I
just feel like it's different for Kim do
you know what I mean especially because
okay if Kelly Clarkson had a
balenciagatop in her okay she doesn't
have like closet accounts like Kim does
so no no that's something that's not
what I was gonna say but that's also a
good point let's say she went out to
dinner with gal Pals and she wore a
Balenciaga shirt like
every time Kelly Clarkson leaves the
house it's not a Paparazzi Stampede like
she can privately wear something and not
have everyone know about it okay so
let's to bad example Gwyneth
okay like say the Gwyneth was wearing
like what a turtleneck for her child
that like was Balenciaga from a trial so
she knows that there's like big
Paparazzi see that seems like a
statement to me like okay but like for a
dinner someone who gets [__]
photographed all the time who didn't
have an association with Wednesday the
thing is really nobody out there gets
photographed as much as the Kardashians
who they really don't leave their house
without getting photographed where which
I think is intentional on their part
because it's a part of their job yeah I
think most celebrities can go out to
dinner without being seen honestly okay
but we're not answering Haley Bieber
good question okay that's a very good
Kelly Bieber in the midst of all of her
outfits was wearing a turtleneck
underneath a Blazer that was Balenciaga
would this be news well the thing is is
that Haley Bieber didn't ever really
have a connection to Balenciaga so it's
like we're not talking about Haley
Bieber and Balenciaga because it was
never anything to talk about we're
talking about Kim and Balenciaga because
there was a lot to discuss and I never
[__] heard from her yeah
okay so it's a kitten thing yeah yeah
okay I can I can see that I'm not I'm
glad we got down I'm glad you asked
those questions I know you're one point
or the other I'm just trying to place it
in different contexts so I can see it
clearly by the way so am I like I'm I'm
confused by this whole thing like I
don't know what the [__] I'm talking
about like ask all your questions like
I'm just making this up yeah I'm just
saying like it's [__] weird and we
like never heard from her and like there
was this whole disgusting thing and like
a lot of people were upset with her and
it has been the reason for like this
whole kind of flop era and we still
haven't heard from her and they're like
teasing that they'll talk about on the
show and I feel like they won't and then
she's wearing one yeah I feel like
they're not going to talk about it on
the show just because they would have
said Balenciaga in the trailer once or
they would have referenced it like a
little bit more specifically right to
get us excited yeah that's no I feel I
feel like they don't so it's this whole
Saga that really like really affected
them and they won't talk about it yeah
but now she's wearing Balenciaga again
so to me it's it's part of the
conversation that she's wearing it again
okay that is where I'll leave
that's where I'll leave that and
I
I'm I'm I hear you
I don't know exactly like what I think
she should do with all that neither
what she should do you like donate it
she has so much stuff like she probably
didn't pay for it it's really it won't
hurt her no no it won't and everyone's
making it now like you said so astutely
so many of the clothes that she wore
during her real like ERA with them were
so [__] ugly that really it's a
win-win for everybody yeah who who makes
this pink jacket she was wearing um
hmm
I don't see it in the option anyway
moving on to our next story which I'm
really interested by because the author
James Patterson
you know him of course he's like the
biggest I'm familiar and he was in the
Filthy Rich Jeffrey Epstein documentary
because he lived next door to him in
Palm Beach and he's written fiction and
non-fiction books we did him for the
redheads he wrote a book with Dolly
Parton run Rose run
um one of the biggest authors in the
world just in case oh okay but this we
need to set the stage because of what he
did it's really impactful he accuses the
New York Times of cooking its best
sellers list in a blistering letter to
the editor that they refuse to publish
so James Patterson obviously been on the
New York Times bestseller list a million
times first he posted two tweets just
like questioning the
math the math wasn't mathing for him he
said what's up with New York Times
bestsellers list any anybody besides me
noticed that Mike pompeo's book sold
more copies than who's Mike Pompeo the
former Secretary of political political
yeah yeah he said anyone noticed that
he's not James getting political I sold
more copies than six titles on today's
list and I guess like he wasn't on it
then he said and last week JD Robb
that's Nora Roberts's pen name novel
wasn't on the fiction list even though
it was still selling more than four
other titles there by bestseller does
the times mean best for their target
audience yeah okay so and then he wrote
a huge letter to the editor that they
were refused to publish saying that he's
a long time reader of the New York Times
it's his favorite newspaper he's been
reading it since he moved to New York in
1971 here are some of the poll quotes I
also know that this Spirit of
self-criticism and getting it right is
too often absent from the best sellers
list he said the real problem is where
you say sales are statistically weighted
to represent an accurately reflect all
Outlets proportionally Nationwide
because here you suggest your process
has statistical rigor and it simply
doesn't as the nation's bookstores and
our publishing houses have known for
years and can prove your lists too often
are outside the realm of statistically
possible much less plausible right the
fact is that you regularly publish even
now that we have computers in widely
available data lists that say a book
sold better or worse than another even
when it's probably wrong oh my God I
feel like so strongly about this because
I was on the list and I um and I was so
grateful to be on the list even though
in terms of sales like I absolutely
deserved it but so when I when I was
publishing my book I was like doing a
lot of research on the New York Times
like how do you get on how many do you
really need to sell and I was shocked to
discover that the New York Times
bestsellers list is an editorial
list meaning it's curated it's not um
based on statistics it's not one two
three four five like it's basically
opinion it's an editorial
um and so when you look at like USA
Today charts which are statistically
just based on number of books sold that
to me is and it sucks that like
everybody puts so much weight on New
York Times bestseller because in order
to make New York Times bestsellers you
have to sell enough books but you also
have to then be like approved slash
chosen by the editors of the New York
Times which is hard to do especially
because the New York Times is
technically a political newspaper it's
like more liberal leaning so if your
book might not align with all their you
know agenda then you would have a less
likelihood of getting on the list so
when when you look at the USA Today I
find the USA Today lists to me more
interesting because it goes in order
this person sold 10 books this person
sold nine books this person sold five
books like it's based on numbers and so
like not to make literally everything
about me but I found it really
interesting how I was number 12. and I'm
I'm just supporting James's Theory I'm
not making the story
if I ever read another book I would love
to be on the list but like and I'm not
saying in any way like I'm comparable to
this person but my book came out and
when you when you have your first week
sales that includes all pre-orders all
pre-orders so the three months leading
up I had all those sales and the first
week so I had
13 weeks of sales
and on the USA Today list I believe I
was I don't know what number I was but I
know I was above Michelle Obama whose
book had been out for two years at this
point so I'm not saying my book was
bigger than Michelle Obama's I'm just
saying in three months and one week that
I did pre-sales I did sell more books
than the one week Michelle Obama two
years later right I'm just trying to
give contacts and so I was above because
I just my pre-orders that's it USA Today
on USA Today I was above and then on New
York Times she was like number three and
I was number 12. so it just doesn't make
sense in terms of numbers but I'm not
saying in any way that I'm a better book
well actually no I'm kidding that my
book has anyway comparable to Michelle
Obama I was just talking about
statistics right I know people are going
to drag me for like bringing that up but
I just thought it was interesting
um and so when I had learned that when I
was doing research because I really
wanted to get on the list it was like a
huge goal of mine I was like almost
disheartened because it's like you can
sell you could literally sell 10 million
books and you could not get on the list
just because
you know somebody at the New York Times
doesn't like you and I'm not a media
darling you could you could said 10
million and you will you have to sell an
absurd amount right I don't know what
the number is but you have to sell an
absurd amount of books to make the list
no matter how much they don't want you
to make it right you know no and he's
right we regard it as like this Beacon
but also this is what he said and he
makes some fire points he said look I
know somebody's gonna accuse me of
pursuing self-interest here and they
would be right I'm an author I love
landing on the list that gets more
attention than any other list in the
country a list that brings additional
visibility and attention to the books
its names a list that has I imagine it
should be easy enough for an economist
to prove actual monetarily value for
authors and Publishing houses yeah and a
list that can make or break the careers
of new writers maybe I'm foolish for
thinking best seller is supposed to be a
measure of what's most popular with my
fellow book buying readers as opposed to
sometimes decreed value judgment on the
method by which the books were sold at
any rate I'm asking you to please cut it
out by the way that's actually a really
good point especially for like new auth
there's and that's the thing with like
Tick Tock now it's like so many books go
viral and they're selling crazy amounts
of copies like people are so influenced
buying on their Kindles and it doesn't
really they don't make the list but
they're selling like thousands and
thousands of books you know years after
the book has been published and if it
had made the New York Times bestsellers
list that's such a huge
platform because people go to the New
York Times bestseller list to choose
their next book of course and it's it's
printed it's one of the most widely
distributed widely circulated newspapers
in the country like it's basically a
billboard for your book yes also and
then they also only sell they only print
the first 10 so I didn't even make the
print version they can choose whatever
books they want like it's their
newspaper but then you can't accurately
call it a Best Sellers List it could be
called The New York Times book list yeah
the New York Times recommended booklet
you know and it's like and then it's an
amalgamation of sales and curation and
our taste uh but it's not a Best Sellers
List no it's a curated
list of recommendations and to put it
honestly he's so right to put it as a
Best Sellers List in number order when
it actually is not accurately
based on numbers shouldn't that that's
like
for not only is it factually incorrect
but it's also like false advertising
yeah to say that like you know uh I'm
just making this up like crying in H
Mart is the number one book and I'm sure
it was but I don't know why I'm using
that book as an example but to say that
any book is the number one book in the
country right now when actually there
are other books that sold more copies
that's just misleading and factually
incorrect yes also and maybe they should
also look into their dagger system
because I got a dagger and that's
something I just will never stop talking
about because I didn't [__] deserve
one no literally but they say that the
panel of reporting retails is
comprehensive and reflects sales in tens
of thousands of stores of all sizes and
demographics across the US so they make
it really vague that it's like oh you
could never know what happens in tens of
thousands of stories but we know and
this is the best sellers he said that
should be reassuring but it's not
because it's Bonkers it's an excuse tens
of thousands of bookstores we would be a
happier and less dysfunctional Nation if
it were true but it's regrettably not
maybe you mean locations that sell books
and you include grocery stores
newsstands Amazon lockers and yard sales
but that's a quibble yeah there's really
no way to know there's yeah you're
saying the list isn't what we think it
is because you're combing through mom
and pop grocery stores like that's such
a lie yeah no and I think like people
only realize it when they write a book
and of course everybody wants to make
the best sellers it's like a dream I
can't stop talking about it the fact
that I made it it's equal parts ego and
um no it's ego like it's no but what he
says is extremely true like if you make
that list it's the difference between
your book being seen by millions of
people and not yeah yeah so it's it's
business too it's not just about like oh
this feels nice yeah and even though it
does feel nice and it's not they they
offer no they're not transparent about
it at all again not to make everything
about me but when I got a dagger on my
list I my publisher which is like a
really it's Simon Schuster was like a
legit Publishing House I asked them to
reach out to New York Times I would be
happy to provide any like I did when
they put a dagger next to your name it's
like yeah this person sold a lot of
books but we have reason to believe that
maybe they bulk bought their own book
and I was like okay
um so I asked him to reach out I said I
would provide anything like I didn't
want the dagger to live on the website
like I am not worthy of a dagger never
heard like they weren't willing they
never responded they never gave anything
and so they're not willing to work with
writers or public they're very rigid
yeah so I think that everybody has
complained over the years you know this
person didn't make it it's
infighting and this and that and Dagger
and such but when James Patterson is
saying it yeah and he's made he owns the
list he makes it no matter what like
he's a darling of the literacy world
it's impossible to ignore yeah but I
also think some of his books he said he
wrote a book about uh police
um
American police it was like Illuminating
first-hand stories and it didn't make
the list they said that I don't know
they said some [__] about that so
he's experienced it when it's not you
know Alex Cross right right right he
would assume and to see like a book of
his not make the list like that's
impossible that's impossible because to
be honest people are really surprised
because like books aren't really what
they use I think a lot of people think
in order to make a list you have to sell
like a million books to make it one of
the lists I think you need like a good
minimum of like six thousand copies in
three months six thousand and be a
favorable person and be a favorable
person so if you're an unfavorable
person right how many you think you have
to sell in the first week of sales to be
like impossible to ignore
it also depends what else came out that
week and such it does it does I'm okay
so I am a year uh I have to say you know
above 15 000.
yeah but sometimes you'll see someone on
the list and it's like
I'm sorry nobody's buying that book you
didn't even chart on Amazon bro right
that's the other thing now we have
that's exactly what he's saying we have
access to so much data we're able to
look in real time at Amazon at the you
know audiobook bookstore at the uh the
Kindle bookstore like yeah you could
really see that [__] is updated multiple
times a day you can see what books are
popular he said he gets his info from
book scan I think that literally tells
you how many books so I actually like a
year like an LA person look at book scan
no you have to like I think register as
an author which I did and then I never
checked it I really should check it
charity lit we need those information I
know
um yes we have so much data it's like
come on who do you think you're fooling
maybe back in the day everyone would
flock to New York Times because wow they
sold a lot of books but we have so much
access especially as authors and it must
be really disheartening to have like a
really great week with your book and
think you're gonna get it and really be
eligible but not get it but I will say
on the flip side because we have all of
these other methods of seeing charts
just that we we can use them to disprove
the New York Times but it also helps
Elevate those exact books that we're
talking about like I don't necessarily
get my book recommendations from New
York Times I get them from Amazon charts
I get them from Goodreads charts yeah in
the same way that oh we have all those
charts that we can see that you're wrong
we also all have all those charts we
could see what's actually popular well
then it's like we as a society need to
stop putting so much emphasis and
importance on the New York Times list
because we know now when James Patterson
has validated that it's actually not a
legitimate list yeah but it's just the
culture we live in like even me I'm like
ragging on the list you will not catch
me go one day without telling people I
made the New York Times like we put so
much importance on it the unfortunate
importance of the New York Times it's so
like it's unfortunate I know by the way
I know it's fraudulent like I have had a
firsthand experience at it being
fraudulent and it's still one of my
greatest accomplishments how sad is that
Beyond
yeah and that's just a little bit about
me being a loser I doubt anything will
change but this is definitely a big
Spotlight it might be helpful if like
other big authors
join them you know yeah but it's like on
the one hand you have to be big enough
that doesn't matter if they hate you
right you want to get on the bad side
yeah but if you're like you know you're
Taylor Jenkins read and you're creeping
up and you're finally having your moment
in the sun it's like I'll show every man
for himself yeah Colleen Hoover is like
yeah killing it but even Colleen Hoover
like technically there should be weeks
where she's the only person on the list
right and also I feel like when she was
like only doing ebooks for certain of
her books like those books before she
was the Talk of the Town those books
probably were selling a couple thousand
copies in a given week there are lists
like that are strictly ebooks and she
probably was snubbed a number of times
before they just like decided she's not
ignorable before they decided to
platform her yeah like it's almost like
an endorsement yeah I think that's how
they see it yeah
it's [__]
that's why you should become a redhead
because we don't do any crap like this
no and they are a data based book club
right sure yeah I mean we each give a
rating we do the average you put data
first and we put in a ranking system we
have a spreadsheet ranking system of the
best books but we also would say that we
don't feel like it accurately reflects
when we think back on all the books that
we've read yeah but new episode that I
had drops this week on Thursday we are
recording today so get your questions in
for your girlies because
we are ready to chit chat because it's
time and because this month's book was
extremely crazy was it divisive
I don't know how it will be divisive I
think that it will just be like a really
passionate episode in terms of like
I didn't like this book got it you know
what I mean but it's like I feel
differently about I didn't like the book
but I feel differently than it's not
like other books I've disliked and love
got it so yeah great discussions coming
up before we dive into the fifth and
final story right for the model Fifth
and final
um
let me just share how today's episode
finally it's brought to you by zoc talk
you've been stewing about a health
problem you have isn't that the truth
Jackie open up
wow I didn't know why we put on the spot
actually Dr patient confidentiality yeah
thanks well you almost resort to texting
your group chat to get your friends
opinions but you're unlikely to find
quality medical advice in your group
chat
um but you can find it on ZocDoc
thousands of medical professionals on
ZocDoc are here to help you they listen
like a friend and give you the expert
care that you need
so it's so easy when you're having a
medical issue to like go down a rabbit
hole of like Google asking people's
recommendations and the next thing you
know you're like diagnosing yourself
with a terminal illness next time just
go to ZocDoc you will find the Expert
Medical and um medical professionals and
doctors that you need that specialize in
the care that you need and they'll
deliver the type of experience that you
want when someone is just exceptionally
good at what they do it could be a
waiter a chef a doctor you just know
you're in good hands
and that's exactly what it's like on
ZocDoc finding the doctor that's right
for you is seamless the quality care you
need is just a few Taps away in the
ZocDoc app
so um
wherever you are whatever you need and
whether you're looking for a new doctor
you moved like Jackie needed a new
dentist wherever you are knew everything
you knew everything ZocDoc is a really
great resource because you can a make
the appointment online so you don't have
to call which is the best two you can
find out if they take your insurance you
don't like waste any of your time and
the next thing you know you're like
sitting in the office of the person
exactly who can help you so there's no
more Dr roulette or scouring the
internet for questionable questionable
reviews go to zocdoc.com toast download
the ZocDoc app for free and then book
find and book a top-rated doctor today
many are available within 24 hours
that's
zocdoc.com toast zocdoc.com
host thank you Claudia you're welcome
our fifth and final story just got
move just got real just not real no it's
a really sweet story um Lamar Odom is
acquiring rehab centers in California
vowing to save lives Lamar Odom has just
invested in three drug treatment centers
in California with the hopes of helping
people turn around their lives just as
he did with his own several years ago
TMZ sports has learned the former LA
Lakers star teamed up with Christian
hip-hop artist Dante Ralston and former
Hall of Fame skateboarder Dennis
Martinez to acquire the facilities in
San Diego El Cajon and Lemon Grove a rep
for Odom tells us the venues consist of
a women's Residential Treatment home and
two men's detox and residential
treatment homes the biddings will
fittingly be called Odum Wellness
treatment centers and Lamar is vowing to
be highly involved with the patients at
the facilities in fact they're told
Lamar is ready to start saving lives
ASAP he wants to help everyone he can he
is thankful that he was given a second
chance at his life and feels his Destiny
is to help others oh this is so sweet
what a great full circle moment it
reminds me of dope sick
yeah how he became you know a
professional I love Lamar Odom I have so
much love in my heart for Lamar Odom I
truly wish Lamar Odom the best and I
think this is beautiful you know I think
this is beautiful too I think it's also
a great way to stay on track with your
sobriety and your um
recovery is to be involved in the
community so I think it's great for him
I think it's great for these
organizations the patients I love this I
love this and he's kind of like becoming
the man that Chloe deserves deserves and
probably always thought he could be I
know and as much as I like love them and
ship them I don't think there is a world
in which no the ship has sailed quite
literally but it's just fun to think
about and I think we've moved on yeah
but he always says nice things about
Chloe he always and he always I mean if
she wanted to he would in a second it's
not even a question but I think he knows
like how he really kind of like [__]
her up and how he's grateful for to be
in a good place with her so I think he's
just you know he's not asking for more
he's just happy with he's going to bloom
where he's planted yeah but if she
called and said get over here he would
be on the next plane he would I love
this I'm really so just a little
heartwarming news to end your Monday
because that was just the craziest
time
when we literally I think he actually
did die and they like brought him back
the Kardashians thought he had passed
away
that was crazy
and not only did he live but he's
helping others paying himself thriving
he's thriving
Thrice and stressing you guys Bruno sat
on my left the whole time he was such a
good boy he needed his mommy today it's
crazy how he will he does not come
upstairs once when we're remote unless
I'm here but when we're together like
all of a sudden it's all pause on death
of course it's a putty it's a putty it's
a Bruno doesn't it's a party Bruno does
not miss a party Bruno is falling asleep
sitting up
because we're very relaxing yeah
uh knowing his two favorite ladies are
together he can rest peacefully and he
successfully got the o on the floor so
he's no competition you know this is the
ideal situation for Bryce and Bruno has
his back to him it's like he's not even
here I love having the boys in studio I
love podcasting with you it's everything
it's such a fun way to start your day
even though oh my God my day started
horribly this morning oh my God I
thought today it was gonna be the worst
day ever because I was um like when I
went in the kitchen to make my coffee I
had to put some things away from the
dishwasher and I broke two ceramic bowls
like shattered yourself no but it was
just like ceramic glass shattered
everywhere who cleaned it up Zach and it
was just a horrible way to start my day
I'm so sorry but you would never know I
felt like the whole day was ruined right
like Dad was setting the tone one of
those days yes but look I had forgotten
we turned it around turn it around turn
around
love you thanks so much for listening to
the toast okay no no he knows on the
love yeah thanks so much for listening
to the toast the millennial Morning Show
where we deal with the fastest I started
saying each and every Friday and
YouTubes are watching this on YouTube
please don't forget subscribe give this
video a thumbs up also available places
we'll see you tomorrow see you tomorrow
love ya bye